the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to get
started my name is Eric Grimson I have
the privilege of serving as mi t--'s
chancellor for academic advancement you
can go look up what that means and like
John I'm a former head of course six and
today are it's hard this term with Anna
and John I'm going to be splitting the
lecture so I'm up today okay last time
and introduced the first of the compound
datatypes tuples and lists she sold Lots
showed lots of ways of manipulating them
lots of built-in things for manipulating
those structures in the key difference
between the two of them was that tuples
were immutable meaning you could not
change them lists were mutable they
could be changed or mutated and that led
to both some nice power and some
opportunities for challenges and in
particular she showed you things like
aliasing where you could have two names
pointing to the same list structure and
because of that you could change the
contents of one it would change the
appearance of the contents of the other
and that leads to some nice challenges
so the side-effects immutability or one
of the things you're going to see both
as a plus and a minus as we go through
the course today we're going to take a
different direction for a little while
we're going to talk about recursion
there's a powerful and wonderful tool
for solving computational problems we're
then going to look at another type of
compound data structure a dictionary
which is also mutable and then we're
going to put the two pieces together and
show how together they actually give you
a lot of power for solving some really
neat problems very effectively but I
want to start with recursion perhaps one
of the most mysterious at least
according to programmers concepts in
computer science one that leads to lots
of really bad computer science jokes
actually all computer science jokes are
bad but these are particularly bad so
let's start with the obvious question
what is recursion if you go to the
ultimate source of knowledge Wikipedia
you get something that says in essence
recursion is the process of repeating
items in a self-similar way well that's
really helpful right
but we're going to see that idea because
recursion is we're going to see in a
second is the idea of taking a problem
and reducing it to a smaller version of
the same problem and using that idea to
actually tackle a bunch of really
interesting problems but recursion gets
used a lot of places so it's this idea
of using or repeating the idea of
multiple times so you know wouldn't it
be great if your 3d printer printed 3d
printers and you could just keep doing
that all the way along or one that's a
little more common it's actually got a
wonderful name is called Me's on a beam
in art sometimes referred to as the
droste effect pictures that have inside
them a picture of the picture which has
inside them a picture of the picture and
you get the idea and of course one of
the things you want to think about in
recursion is not to have it go on
infinitely and yes there are even light
bulb jokes about recursion if you can't
read it it says how many twists does it
take to screw in a light bulb
and it says if it's already screwed in
the answer is zero otherwise twist at
once ask me again add one to my answer
and that's actually a nice description
of recursion so let's look at it more
seriously what is recursion I want to
describe it both abstractly or
algorithmically and semantically or if
you like in terms of programming
abstractly this is a great instance of
something often called divide and
conquer or sometimes called decrease and
conquer and the idea of recursion is I
want to take a problem I'm trying to
solve and say how could I reduce it to a
simpler version of the same problem plus
some things I know how to do and then
that simpler version I'm going to reduce
it again and keep doing that until I get
down to a simple case that I can solve
directly that is how we're going to
think about designing solutions to
problems semantically this is typically
going to lead to the case where a
program a definition a function will
refer to itself in its body it will call
itself inside its body now if you
remember your high school geometry
teacher she probably would rap your
knuckles which you're not allowed to do
because then things like geometry you
can't define something in terms of
itself right that's not allowed in
recursion
is okay our definition of a procedure
can in its body call itself so long as I
have what I call a base case a way of
stopping that unwinding of the problems
when I get to something I can solve
directly and so what we're going to do
is avoid infinite recursion by ensuring
that we have at least one or more base
cases that are easy to solve and then
the basic idea is I just want to solve
the same problem on some simpler input
with the idea of the using that solution
to solve the larger problem okay let's
look at an example and to set the stage
I'm going to go back to something you've
been doing iterative algorithms for
loops while loops they naturally lead to
what we would call iterative algorithms
and these algorithms can be described as
being captured by a set of state
variables meaning a sum one or more
variables that tell us exactly the state
of the computation it's a lot of words
let's look at an example
I know it's trivial but bear with me
suppose I want to do integer
multiplication multiply two integers
together and all I have available to me
is addition so a times B is the same as
adding a to itself B times if I'm
thinking about this iteratively I could
capture this computation with two state
variables one would just call the
iteration number and it would be
something for example that starts at B
and each time through the loop reduces
by one and it will keep doing that until
I've counted down B times and I get down
to zero and at the same time I would
have some value the computation I might
call it result which starts at zero
first time through adds in a next time
through ads and a and it just keeps
track of how many things have I added up
until I get done and yeah I know you
could just do mult
but this is trying to get this idea of
how would I do this iteratively so I
might start off with I saying there be
things still to add and results as one
the first time through the loop I add in
a reduce I by one next time through the
loop I add in another a reduced I by one
and you get the idea I just walk down it
until eventually I got to the end of
this computation so we could write code
for this and actually it should be
pretty straightforward
there it is I'm going to call it multi
two takes in two arguments a and B and
I'm going to capture exactly that
process so notice what I do I set up
result internally is just a little
variable I'm going to use to accumulate
things and then there's the iteration as
long as B is greater than zero what do I
do
add a two result stored away reduce B by
one and I'll keep doing that until B
gets down to being equal to 0 in which
case I just return the result okay
simple solution now let's think about
this a different way gain a times B is
just adding a to itself B times and
that's the same as a plus adding a to
itself B minus 1 times ok that sounds
like leisure domain that sounds like
just playing with words but it's really
important because what is this ah that's
just a times B minus 1 by the definition
at the top point and I know you're
totally impressed but this is actually
really cool because what have I done
I've taken one problem this one up here
and I've reduced it to a simpler version
of the same problem plus some things I
know how to do and how would I solve
this same trick that's a times a times B
minus 2 I would just unwrap it one more
time and I would just keep doing that
until I get down to something I can
solve directly a base case and that's
easy when B is equal to 1 the answer is
just 8 or I could do one B is equal to 0
the answer is just 0 and there's code to
capture that different form wonderful
compact description what does it say it
says if I'm at the base case if B is
equal to 1 the answer is just a
otherwise I'm going to solve the same
problem with a smaller version and add
it to a and return that result and
that's nice crisp characterization of a
problem recursive definition that
reduces a problem to a simpler version
of the same problem
okay let's look at another example
classic problem in recursions to compute
factorial write n factorial or n bang if
you like and exclamation point is n
times n minus 1 all the way down to 1 so
it's the product of all the integers
from 1 up to n assuming n is a positive
integer so we can ask the same question
if I wanted to solve this recursively
what would the base case be well when n
is equal to 1 it's just 1 in the
recursive case we'll end times n minus 1
all the way down to 1 that's the same as
n times n minus 1 factorial so I can
easily write out the base case and I've
got a nice recursive solution to this
problem okay if you're like me and this
is the first time you see it it feels
like I've taken your head and twisted it
about 180 degrees I'm going to take it
another 180 degrees because you might be
saying well wait a minute how do you
know what really stops how do you know
it really terminates the computation so
let's look at it there's my definition
for fact short for factorial right fact
event is if n is equal to 1 return 1
otherwise return n times fact of n minus
1 and let's use the tools that Anna
talked about in terms of an environment
at a scope and think about what happens
here so when I read that in or I
evaluate that in Python it creates a
definition that binds the name fact to
some code just all of that stuff over
here plus the name for the formal
parameter hasn't done anything with it
yet and then I'm going to evaluate print
a fact of for print needs a value so it
has to get the value of factor 4 and we
know what that does it looks up fact
there it is its procedure definition so
it creates a new frame a new environment
it calls that procedure and inside that
frame the formal parameter for fact is
bound to the value passed in so n is
bound to 4 that frame is scoped by this
global frame meaning this meaning it's
going to inherit things in the global
frame and what does it do it says inside
of this frame evaluate the
body effect okay so it says is n equal
to 1 nope it's not it's 4
so in that case go to the else statement
and says Oh return n times factor then
and n is 4 fact of n minus 1 says I need
to return four times factor 3 4 is easy
multiplication is easy factor 3 is I
look up fact now I'm in this frame I
don't see fact there but I go up to that
frame there's the definition for fact
we're going to do the rest of this a
little more quickly what does that do it
creates a new frame called by fact and
the argument passed in for n is n minus
1 that value right there of 3 so 3 is
now bound to N
same game evaluate the body is n equal
to 1
no so in that case I'm going to go to
the return statement it says returned
three times fact of 2 and notice it's
only looking at this value of n because
that's the frame in which I mean it
never sees that value of n ok aren't you
glad I didn't do factor 400 we're only
got two more to go but you get the idea
same thing I need to get fact of 2 it's
going to call fact again with n bound to
2 relative that evaluates the body and
is not yet equal to 1 that says I can go
to the else clause and return 2 times
fact of one I call fact again now with n
bound to 1 and fortunately now that
Clause is true and it says return 1 oops
sorry before I do so there's the base
case and it may seem apparent to you but
this is important right I'm unwinding
this until I get to something that can
stop the computation now I'm simply
going to gather the computation up
because it says return one who asked for
it well that called a fact of 1 so that
reduces to return 2 times 1 and who
called for that fact of 2 that reduces
to return of 3 times 2 which reduces to
4 times 6 which reduces to printing out
24 so it unwinds it down to a base case
and it stops a couple of observations
notice how each recursive call creates
its own frame and as a consequence
there's
no confusion about which value of n I'm
using also notice in the other frames
and was not changed we did not mutate it
so we're literally creating a local
scope for that recursive call which is
exactly what we want also notice how
there was a sense of flow of control in
computing fact of something that reduces
to returning n times fact of n minus 1
and that creates a new scope and that
will simply keep unwinding until I get
to something that can return a value and
then I gather all those frames back up
so there's a natural flow of control
here but most importantly there's no
confusion about which variable I'm using
when I'm looking for a value event all
right because this is often a place
where things get a little confusing I
want to do one more example but let me
first show you side-by-side the two
different versions of factorial actually
I lied slightly we didn't show this on
earlier but there's factorial if I
wanted to do it iteratively I'd set up
some initial variable to one and then I
just run through a loop for example from
1 up to just below n minus 1 or 1 up to
n multiplying at it and putting it back
into product returned product which one
do you like more you can't say neither
you have to pick one show of hands how
many of you liked this one some hesitant
ones how many prefer this one yeah
that's my view I'm biased but I really
like the recursive one it is crisper to
look at you can see what it's doing I'm
reducing this problem to simpler version
of that problem pick your own version
but I would argue that the recursive
version is more intuitive to understand
from a programmers perspective it's
actually often more efficient to write
because I don't have to think about
interior interior variables depending on
the machine it may not be as efficient
when you call it because in the
recursive version I've got to set up
that set of frames and some versions of
these languages are actually very
efficient about it some of them a little
less so but given the speed of computers
today who cares as long as it actually
just does the computation all right one
more example how do we really know our
recursive code works well we just did a
simulation but let's look at it one more
way the
version what can I say about it well I
know it's going to terminate because B
is initially positive assuming I gave it
an appropriate value it decreases by 1
every time around this loop at some
point it has to get less than 1 it's
going to stop so I can conclude it's
always going to terminate what about the
recursive version well if I call it with
B equal to 1 I'm done if I call it with
B greater than 1 again it's going to
reduce it by one on the recursive call
which means on each recursive call is
going to reduce it eventually gets down
to a place assuming I gave it a positive
integer where B is equal to 1 so it'll
stop which is good well we just did was
we used a great tool from math second
best department at MIT wow I didn't even
get any hisses on that one John all
right and I'm now in trouble with the
head of the math department so now that
I got your attention and yes all
computer science strokes are bad and
mine are really bad but I'm tenured you
cannot do a damn thing about it
let's look at mathematical induction
which turns out to be a tool that lets
us think about programs in a really nice
way you haven't seen this here's the
idea of mathematical induction if I want
to prove a statement we refer to as
being indexed on the integers in other
words it's some mathematical statement
that runs over integers if I want to
prove it's true for all values of those
integers mathematically I do it by
simply proving it's true for the
smallest value of n typically n is equal
to 0 or 1 and then I do an interesting
thing I say I need to prove that if it's
true for an arbitrary value of n I'm
just going to prove that it's also then
true for n plus 1 and if I can do those
two things I can then conclude for an
infinite number of values of n it's
always true I'm going to relate it back
to programming in a second but let me
show you a simple example of this one
that you may have seen if I add the
integers from 0 up to n or even from 1
up to n I claim that's the same as n
times n plus 1 over 2 so 1 2 3 that's 6
right and that's one exactly right 3
times 4 which is divided by 2 which
gives me out 6
how would I prove this well by induction
and you do the simple cases van a is
equal to zero well then this side is
just 0 and that's 0 times 1 which is 0
divided by true so 0 equals 0 it's true
and now the inductive step I'm going to
assume it's true for some K I should I
pick down but for some K and then what I
need to show is it's true for K plus 1
well there's the left-hand side and I
want to show that this is equal to that
and I'm going to do it by using exactly
this recursive idea because what do I
know I know that this sum in here I'm
assuming is true and so that says that
the left-hand side the first portion of
it is just K times K plus 1 over 2
that's the definition of the thing I'm
assuming is true to that I'm going to
add k plus 1 well you can do the algebra
right that's K plus 1 all times K over 2
plus 1 which is K plus 2 over 2 oh cool
it's exactly that having done that I can
now conclude this is true for all values
of n what does it have to do with
programming that's exactly what we're
doing when we think about recursive code
right we're saying show that it's true
for the base case and then what I'm
essentially assuming is that if it works
for values smaller than B then does the
code return the right answer for B and
the answers absolutely it does and I'm
using induction to deduce that in fact
my code does the right thing why am i
torturing you with this because this is
the way I want you to think about
recursion when I'm going to break a
problem down into a smaller version of
the same problem I can assume that the
smaller version gives you the answer all
I have to do is make sure that what I
combined together gives me out the right
result ok you may be wondering what I'm
doing with these wonderful high-tech
toys down here I want to show you
another example of recursion so far
we've seen simple things that just have
one base case and this is a mythical
story called the towers of Hanoi and the
story as I heard it is there's a temple
somewhere in Hanoi
with three tall spikes and 64 jewel
encrusted golden discs all of a
different size they all started out on
one spike with the property that they
were ordered from smallest down to
largest and there are priests in this
temple who are moving the disks one at a
time one per second and their goal is to
move the entire stack from one spike to
another spike in women and when they do
nirvana is achieved and we all get a
really great life
we'll talk separately about how long is
it's going to take because there's one
trick to it they can never cover a
smaller disc with a larger disc as
they're doing it so they got a third
disc as a temporary thing and I want to
show you how to solve this problem
because you're going to write code with
my help in a second or I'm going to
write code with your help in a second to
solve so let's look at it so watch
carefully moving a disc of size 1 well
that's pretty easy right moving a disc
of size 2 we'll just put this one on the
spare one while you move it over so you
don't cover it up that's easy moving a
disc of size 3 got to be a little more
careful you can't cover up a smaller one
with a larger one so you have to really
think about where you're putting it
would help if these things didn't juggle
and there you go you got it done all
right
you're watching got to do for to do for
again you've got to be really careful
not to cover things up as you do this
you want to get the bottom one
eventually exposed and so you're going
to pull that one over there if you do
the powder really well you won't notice
if I make a serious mistake as I'm doing
this which I just did but I'm going to
cover from that and do it that way to
put this one over here and that one goes
there and if I did this in Harvard
Square I could make money there you go
right ok got the solution see how to
solve it could you write code for this
yeah maybe not that's on quiz right
thanks John don't tell him us on the
quiz damn alright I'm going to claim
though that in fact there's a beautiful
recursive solution and here's the way to
think about it recursively I want to
move a tower of size n I'm going to
assume I can move smaller towers and
then it's real easy what I do I take a
stack of size n minus 1 I move it onto
the spare one I move the bottom one over
and then I move a stack of size n minus
1
there it's beautiful recursive solution
and how do I move this smaller stack
just the same way I just unwind it
simple and in fact the code follows
exactly that okay I do a little larger
domain up here to try and get your
attention but notice by doing that what
I do I asked you to think about a
recursively the recursive solution when
you see it is in fact very
straightforward and there's the code
dead trivial well dead trivial is unfair
but it's very simple right I simply
write something so let me describe it I
need to say how big a tower am i moving
and i'm going to label the three stacks
a from a two and a spare I have a little
procedure that just prints out the move
for me and then what's the solution if
it's just a stack of size one just print
the move take it to from from from to
two otherwise move a tower of size n
minus one from the from spot to the
spare spot then move what's left at our
size one from from two two and then take
that thing I stuck on spare and move it
over to two and I'm done in that code
that we had that out you'll see this
code you can run it I'm not going to
print it out because if I did use it's
going to say okay it looks like it does
the right kind of thing look at the code
nice and easy and that's what we'd like
you to do when you're given a problem we
asked you to think about it recursively
how do I solve this with a smaller
version of the same problem and then how
do I use that to build the larger
solution this case is a little different
you could argue that this is not really
a recursive call here it's just moving
the bottom when I could have done that
directly but I've got two recursive
calls in the body here I have to move a
smaller stack twice we're going to come
back to that in a little bit let me show
you one other example of recursion that
runs a little bit differently in this
case it's going to have multiple base
cases and this is another very old
problems called the Fibonacci numbers
it's based on something from several
centuries ago when a gentleman named
Leonardo of Pisa also known as Fibonacci
asked the following challenge so I'm
going to put a newborn
of rabbits one male and one female into
an enclosure a pan of some sort and
those rabbits have the following
properties they mate at age one month so
they take a month to mature after a
one-month gestation period they produce
another pair of rabbits a male and a
female and he says I'm going to assume
that the rabbits never die so each month
mature females are going to produce
another pair and his question was how
many female rabbits are there at the end
of a year or two years or three years so
ideas I start off with too immature
rabbits after one month they've matured
which means after another month they
will have both they were sorry they will
have produced a new pair after another
month that mature pair is produced
another pair and the immature pair has
matured which means after another month
those two mature pairs are going to
produce offspring and that immature
Paris has matured and you get the idea
and after several months you get to
Australia you can also see this is going
to be interesting to think about how do
you compute this but what I want you to
see is the recursive solution to it so
how could we capture this well here's
another way of thinking about it after
the first month and I know we're going
to do this funny thing we're going to
index at zero so I'll call at month zero
there is one female which is immature to
the second month that female is mature
and now pregnant which means after the
third month it is produced an offspring
and more generally at the end month
after we get past the first few cases
what do we have any female that was
there two months ago has produced an
offspring because it's taken at least
one month to mature if it hasn't already
been mature and then it's going to
produce an offspring and any female that
was around last month is still around
because it never died off so this is a
little different this is now the number
of females at month n is the number of
females at month n minus one plus the
number of females at month n minus two
so two recursive calls but with
different arguments
different from towers of Hanoi where
there were two recursive calls but with
the same size problem okay
so now I need two base cases one for
when n is equal to zero one frame when n
is equal to one and then I've got that
recursive case and so there's a nice
little piece of code Fibonacci I'm going
to assume X is an integer greater than
or equal to zero I'm going to return
Fibonacci of X and you can see now it
says if either X is equal to zero or X
is equal to one I'm going to return 1
otherwise I reduce it to two simpler
versions of the problem but with
different arguments and I add them up
okay and if we go look at this we can
actually run this I can find my code
which is right there
and I'm just going to so we can for
example check it by saying fib of 0 that
is it a I just hit a bug which I don't
see let me try it again
I'll try it one more time with fib of 0
darn it's really naughty try it I got
two different versions of fib in here
that's what I've got going on so let me
do it again let's do fib of 1 there we
go
fib of 2 just to fib of 3 which is 3 and
fib of 4 which should add the previous
two which gives me 5 there we go sorry
about that I had two versions of fib in
my file which is why you complained at
me and which is why you should always
read the error instructions because it
tells you what you did wrong let's go on
and look at one more example of doing
recursion and we're going to
dictionaries and we're going to pull it
all together so far we been doing
recursion on numerical things we can do
it on non numerical things so a nice way
of thinking about this is how would I
tell if a string of characters is a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
backwards and forwards probably the most
famous palindrome is attributed to
Napoleon Abel was i ere I saw Elba given
that a Pulliam was French I really doubt
he said Abel was i ere I saw Elba but
it's a great palindrome another one
attributed Anne Michaels are we not
drawn onward we fruit viva we few drawn
onward to a new era reads the same
backwards and forwards it's fun to think
about how do you create the palindromes
I want to write code to solve this again
I want to think about it recursively so
here's what I'm going to do I'm first
going to take a string of characters
reduce them all to lowercase and strip
out spaces and punctuation I just want
the characters okay and once I got that
I want to say is that string that list
of characters or that collection of
characters I should say a palindrome and
I'm going to think about it recursively
and that's actually pretty easy if it's
either 0 or 1 long it's a palindrome
otherwise you could think about having
an index at each end of this thing and
sort of counting into the middle but
it's much easier to say take the 2 at
the end if they're the same then check
to see what's left in the middle is a
palindrome and if those two properties
true I'm done and notice what I just did
I nicely reduced a bigger problem to a
slightly smaller problem so exactly what
I want to do okay so what says to check
is this I'm going to reduce it to just
the string of characters and then I'm
going to check that's a palindrome by
pulling those two off and checking to
see they're the same and then checking
to see if the middle is itself a
palindrome okay how would I write it on
the create procedure up here is
palindrome I'm going to have inside of
it two internal procedures that do the
work for me the first one is simply
going to reduce this to all lowercase
with no spaces and notice what I can do
because s is a string of characters I
can use the built in string method lower
so there's that dot notation s dot lower
says apply the method lower to a string
I need an open and close paren to
actually call that procedure and that
will mutate s to just be all lowercase
and then I'm going to run a little loop
I'll set up answer or ants to be an
empty string and then for everything
inside that mutated string I'll simply
say if it's inside this string if it's a
letter add it in to answer if it's a
space or a comma or something else I'll
ignore it and when I'm done just return
answer strips it down to lowercase and
then I'm going to pass that into is pal
which simply says if this is either 0 or
1 long it's a palindrome return true
otherwise check to see that the first
and last element of the string are the
same notice the indexing to get into the
last element and similarly just slice
into the string ignoring the first and
last element and ask is that a
palindrome and then just call it and
that'll do it and again there's a nice
example of that in the code I'm not
going to run out of let you just go look
at it but it will actually pull out
something that checks is this a
palindrome notice again what I'm doing
here i'm doing dividing conquer i'm
taking a problem reducing it keep saying
this to a simpler version of the same
problem
keep unwinding it till i get down to
some
can solve directly in my base case and
I'm done and that's really the heart of
thinking about recursive solutions to
problems I would hope that one of the
things you remember besides my really
lousy patter up here is the idea of
towers of Hanoi because to me it's one
of the nicest examples of a problem that
would be hard to solve iteratively but
when you see the recursive solution it's
pretty straightforward keep that in mind
as you think about doing recursion okay
let's switch gears and let's talk very
briefly about another kind of data type
called a dictionary in the idea of a
dictionary I'm going to motivate with a
simple example there's a quiz coming up
on Thursday I know you don't want to
hear that but there is which means we're
going to be recording grades and so
imagine I wanted to build a little
database just to keep track of grades of
students so one of the ways I could do
it as I could create a list with the
names of the students I could create
another list with their grades and a
third list with the actual subject or
course from which they got that grade
keep a separate list for each one of
them keep them of the same length and in
essence what I'm doing here is I'm
storing information at the same index in
each list so Anna who's going to have to
take the class again gets a B John who's
created the class gets an A+ sorry Anna
John's had a longer time at it all right
bad jokes aside what I'm doing is I
could imagine just creating lists I
could create lists of lists but a simple
ways to do lists we're basically at each
index I've got associated information
it's a simple way to deal with it
getting a grade out takes a little bit
of work because if I want to get the
grade associated with a particular
student what would I do I would go into
the name list and use the method index
which you've seen before again notice
the dot notation it says this is a list
use the index method call it on student
and whatever the value of student is it
will find that in the list return the
index at that point and then I can use
that to go in and get the grade in the
course
and return something out simple way to
do it put a little ugly alright because
among other things I've got things store
in different places in the list I got to
think about if I'm going to add
something the list I got to put them in
the same spot in the list I've got to
remember to always index using integers
is what which is what we know how to do
with lists at least so far it would be
nice if I had a better way to do it and
that's exactly what a dictionary is
going to provide for me
so rather than indexing on integers I'd
like to index directly on the item of
interest I'd like to say where's Anna's
record and find that in one data
structure and so whereas a list is
indexed by integers and has elements
associated with it a dictionary is going
to combine a key or if you like a name
of some sort with an actual value and
we're going to index just by the name or
the label as we go into it so let me
show you some examples first of all to
create a dictionary I use curly braces
open close curly brace so an empty
dictionary would be simply that call if
I want to create an actual dictionary
before I insert things into it I use a
little bit of a funky notation it is a
key or a label a colon and then a value
in this case the string Anna and the end
of and the string B followed by a comma
which separates it from the next pairing
of a key and a label or key and a value
and so on and so if I do this what it
does in my dictionary is it creates
pairings of those labels with the values
I associated with them
okay these are pretty simple but in fact
there's lots of nice things we can do
with it so once we've got them indexing
now is similar to a list but not done by
a number it's done by a value so if
that's my key I can say what's John's
great notice the call it's grades which
is my dictionary open close square
brackets with the label John and what it
does it goes in and finds that in the
dictionary returns the value associated
with it if I ask for something not in
the dictionary it's going to give me a
key R other things we can do with
dictionaries we can add entries just
like we would do with lists
grades as a dictionary and open and
close square brackets I put in a new
label and a value and that adds that to
the dictionary I can test if something's
in the dictionary by simply saying is
this label in grades and it simply
checks all of the labels or the keys for
the dictionary to see if it's there and
if it's not returns false I can remove
entries del something we've seen before
a very generic thing it will delete
something and in this case it says in
the dictionary grades find the entry
associated with that key sorry Ana
you're about to be flushed remove it
she's only getting a B in the class and
she teaches it we got to do something
about this right okay so I can add
things I can delete things I can test if
things are there let me show you a
couple of other things about
dictionaries I can ask for all of the
keys in the dictionary notice the format
there's that dot notation grades as a
dictionary says use the keys method
associated with this data structured
dictionaries open close actually calls
it and it gives me back a collection of
all the keys in some arbitrary order I'm
going to use a funny term here which I'm
not certain we've seen so far it returns
something we call an iterable it's like
range think of it as giving us back the
equivalent of a list it's not actually
list but it's something we could walk
down which is exactly why I can then say
is something in a dictionary because it
returns this set of keys and I can test
to see something's in there I can
similarly get all of the values if I
wanted to look at them giving us out two
intervals here are the key things to
keep in mind about dictionaries the
values can be anything any type mutable
immutable they could be duplicates that
actually makes sense I could have the
same value associated that for example
the same grade associated with different
people that's perfectly fine the values
could be lists they could be other data
structures they could even be other
dictionaries they can be anything which
is great the keys the first part of it a
little more structure
they need to be unique well duh that
makes sense if I have the same key in
two places in the dictionary when I go
to look it up how am I going to know
which one I want so it needs to be
unique and they also need to be
immutable which also makes sense if I'm
storing something in a key in the
dictionary and I can go and change the
value of the key how am I going to
remember what I was looking for so they
can only be things like intz flows
strings tuples boolean's I don't
recommend using floats because you need
to make sure it's exactly the same float
and that sometimes a little bit
challenging but nonetheless you can have
any immutable type as your key and
notice that there's no order to the keys
or the values they are simply stored
arbitrarily by the by Python as it puts
them in and so if I compare these two
lists our ordered sequences index by
integers I look them up by integer index
and the indices have to have an order as
a consequence dictionaries are this nice
generalization arbitrarily match keys to
values I simply look up one item by
looking up things under the appropriate
key all I requires that the keys have to
be immutable okay I want to do two last
things seven minutes to go here I want
to show you an example of using
dictionaries and I'm going to do this
with a little bit more interesting I
hope example I'm going to analyze song
lyrics now I'm going to show you you can
already tell the difference between my
age and Anna's age she used Taylor Swift
and Justin Bieber I'm going to use the
Beatles that's more my generation most
of you never heard of the Beatles unless
you watch shining time station where you
saw Ringo Starr right okay what I'm
going to do is I want to write us a
little set of procedures that record the
frequencies of words in a song lyric so
I'm going to match strings or words to
integers how many times did that that
word appear in the in the song lyric and
then I'm going to ask can I easily
figure out which words occur most often
and how many times I'm going to gather
them together to see what are the most
common words in here and I'm going to do
that where I'm going to let a user say I
want every word that appears more than
some number of times it's a simple
example but I want you to see how
mutation of the dictionary gives you a
really powerful tool for solving this
problem
so let's write the code to do that it's
also in the handout
here we go lyrics to frequencies lyrics
is just a list of words strings so I'm
going to set up an empty dictionary
there's that open closed curly brace and
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
walk through all the words in lyrics
you've seen this before this is looping
over for every word in lyrics notice
what I'm going to do I'm going to simply
say so first part is I can easily
iterate over the list but now I'm going
to say if the word is in the dictionary
and because the dictionary is iterable
simply going to give me back all of the
keys it's simply going to say in this
case if it's in the dictionary okay it's
already there I've got some value
associated with it get the value out add
one to it put it back in okay if it's
not already in the dictionary this is
the first time I've seen it just store
it into the dictionary and when I'm done
just return the dictionary okay so I'm
going to if I can do this right with my
Python show you an example of this and I
have put in one of the great classic
Beatles songs you might recognize it
right there mostly because it's got a
whole lot of repetitions of things so
she loves you yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry
actually they sing it better than I just
did it sarcastically sorry about that
but I thought she loves you there and
here's my code up here lyrics to
frequency so let's see what happens if
we call it and we say lyrics to
frequencies if she loves you and it
would help if I can type alright we'll
try it one more time lyrics to
frequencies she loves you
cool this gave me back a dictionary you
can see the curly braces and there are
all the words that appear in there in
the number of times that they appear
what's the order you don't care you
don't know what we want to do is to
think about how can we analyze it so
let's go back and look at the last piece
of this which is okay I can compute or
convert lyrics to frequencies
so here's the next thing I want to do
how do I find the most common words well
here's what I'm going to do frequencies
is the dictionary something that I just
pulled out okay so I can use the values
method on it which returns an iterable
as I said earlier again notice the
open/close because I got to call it that
gives me back an interval that is all of
the frequencies inside of there because
it's an iterable I can use max on it and
it will take that interval and give me
back the biggest value I'm going to call
that best I'm going to set up words to
be an empty list and then I'm just going
to walk through all of the entries in
the dictionary saying if the value at
that entry is equal to best add that
entry into words just append it onto the
end of the list and when I'm done all of
that loop I'm just going to return a
tuple of both the collections of words
that appeared that many times and how
often they appeared I'm going to show
you an example a second but notice I'm
simply using the properties of the
dictionary the last thing I want to do
then is say I want to see how often the
words appear so I'm going to give it a
dictionary and a minimum number of times
and here I'm going to set result up to
be an empty list I'm going to create a
flag called false it's going to keep
track of when I'm done and as long as
I'm not yet done I'll call that previous
procedure that's going to give me back
the most common words and how often they
appeared I check remember it was a tuple
how often do they appear if it's bigger
than the thing I'm looking for I'll add
that into my result and then the best
part is I'm now going to walk through
all the words that appeared that many
times and just delete them from the
dictionary I can mutate the dictionary
and by doing that I can go back around
and do this again and it will pull out
how many times has disappeared and keep
doing it when I go all the way through
that if I can't find anymore I'll set
the flag to true which means it will
drop out of here and return the result
and if you I'm going to let you run this
yourself if you do that you'll find that
it comes up with not surprisingly I
think yeah is the most common one and
she loves you followed by loves and a
few others what I want you to see here
is how the dictionary captured the
pieces we wanted to very last one
there's Fibonacci as we called it before
it's actually incredibly inefficient
because if I call it I have to do all
the sub calls until I get down to the
base case which is okay but notice every
other thing I do here I've actually
computed those values I'm wasting
measures or wasting time now it's not so
bad with fib of 5 this is fib of 20
almost everything on the right-hand side
of this tree I've already computed once
it means fibs very inefficient I can
improve it by using a dictionary very
handy tool I'm going to call fib not
only with a value of n but a dictionary
which initially I'm going to initialize
to the base cases and notice what I do
I'm going to say if I've already
computed this just return the value in
the dictionary if I haven't go ahead and
do the computation store it in the
dictionary at that point and return the
answer different way of thinking about
it and the reason this is really nice
it's a method called memoization is if I
call fib of 30 for the standard way it
takes 11 million-plus recursive calls to
get the answer out takes a long time of
giving some code for you can try it and
see how long it takes using the
dictionary to keep track of intermediate
values 65 calls and if you try it you'll
see the difference in speed as you run
this so dictionaries are valuable not
only for just storing away data they're
valuable on procedure calls when those
intermediate values are not going to
change and what you're going to see as
we go along is we're going to use
exactly these ideas using dictionaries
to capture information but especially
using recursion to break bigger problems
down into smaller versions of the same
problem to use that as a tool for
solving what turned out to be really
complex things and what that we'll see
you next time
you